welcome coffin silica ice today we have
a bit of a different thing going on
we're gonna do I don't know what to call
this series yet but we're gonna start
talking to people who run real
businesses with legit jobs to teach some
of you guys that after you get out of
the Guru bubble what do you do how can
you set yourself up for success and I
know a lot of you guys some of you want
to go alternate career paths I'm a big
fan of trade school I don't think
everyone needs to go to college so for
our first guest today I'm very too happy
to have probably the biggest plumber on
YouTube
Rodger Wakefield who's here to tell us a
bit about the plumbing trade I can get
into it
and why you should consider it as a
viable career option thank you for our
thanks for coming on the show
no thanks for having me here I
appreciate it yeah so to get into it I
think more than most trades people think
of maybe plumbing as like dirty they
don't really understand what goes on in
a day in the life and sure I'm sure you
get your hands dirty from time to time
but tell me a bit about how you got
started I was actually 16 years old I
was managing a restaurant I was a junior
in high school and late one night I'm
working with a real good friend of mine
and I mean still one of our best friends
today and we're talking and I had
actually quit school and he looked at me
said you know so what are you gonna do
these are you gonna manage restaurants
forever and I said I'm 16 years old I'm
managing a restaurant
life is good I was probably making five
bucks an hour or something and he said
you know what happens if you get fired
there's gonna hire a 16 year old
restaurant manager and it was crazy not
long after that I either quit or got
fired
I contacted he was telling me that not
about his three brothers and his father
that were all plumbers and I remembered
that conversation so I contacted one of
his brothers I got into plumbing and I
fell in love with it I found out later
that I had to have my diploma or
something in order to get my plumbing
license so I went ahead and luckily I
was far enough ahead
when I quit so I went back to high
school graduated with my class and got
back into plumbing and that's how it all
started for me you said you fell in love
with it that's what I'm most interested
in because I think a lot of people they
think of life callings as if some siren
in the sky is gonna sing down to them
and say you should be EA whatever and
I'm of the mindset this is my personal
belief that you fall in love with what
you're an expert at and as you get
better at something you fall in love
with it more because your expertise
really conveys the sense of like purpose
and meaning did you find that to be true
or how did you fall in line with
plumbing in the beginning it was it was
something I enjoyed we were literally it
was a remodel a commercial remodel is
the very first project ever did but it
blew my mind how you could take a
building and add on to it in town to the
existing plumbing electrical structure
and just make it bigger and I tell
people all the time if you're interested
in getting into the trades and remember
not just plumbing but the trades and I
tell people you know do you like to
build things who do you like to fix
things if you like to build things you
probably want to get into the new
construction end of it if you like to
fix things you probably want to get into
the service side of it and then I go on
from there and I ask people do you want
to do residential which is just one or
two storey houses something like that
right or do you want to do commercial
and build big office buildings one of
the biggest jobs that I ever did is I
built the two million square foot
community hospital here in Dallas
Parkland Hospital and it was amazing
loved it
I've done some great things and
thoroughly enjoy it but now what I do is
I do residential service so when I open
my own company I knew it's gonna be
easier for me to start a residential
service company than it is anything else
so I always ask people build things or
fix things commercial or residential and
then my last question is union or
non-union when I got into plumbing I
just wanted to be a plumber that's all I
know
now there's so much more about it the
opportunities and things you can learn
and things you can do so it's been very
interesting yeah so I'm sorry if you can
hear my dog in the background he's he's
going crazy right now
thank God thank God it's yours my dogs
here it is it's in the other office that
I'm hearing it too the headphones I can
hear that at all yeah no I guess it's
yours cuz I kept thinking God if that's
Harley I wish they'd make him be quiet
yes I tried muting myself doing your
instrument
we're both dog guys people get over it
it's okay that's absolutely right so I
think that's a really interesting side
as people I think just due to a lack of
knowledge and that's what I'm hoping to
somewhat address in this series is a
lack of knowledge about how broad and
diverse jobs that you think of it's like
oh you're just a plumber or you're just
an electrician er they think like one
size fits all and the truth about these
jobs is usually that there's a million
different directions you can go with it
I mean you're you said you own your own
company now that's something that I know
a lot of my audience is interested in
and they've perhaps never thought of
like oh this is a viable career path and
a common career path for people in the
trades is to eventually start their own
company when they have you know enough
experience so can you speak a little bit
to that because a lot of my community is
very entrepreneurial minded but they're
just listening to these online gurus
that are telling them you're gonna make
a million dollars in a couple years or
whatever
can you speak to you know your journey
to becoming successful and and how long
it actually takes absolutely I've got
I've got 40 years experience so I've
done this for a long time when I mean
literally when I started 1980 and one of
the things that my buddy told me that
and I he said look robots will never
take this job away from you and at the
time they were talking about look one
day robots are gonna rule the world
we're gonna have flying cars by now I
know y'all getting the same thing we
heard when we were kids just remember
that we heard it a long time ago we're
still not there yet the neat thing about
it though is it's true
robots are never gonna be able to get
out and do the things that we do it
not anytime soon so if you're interested
in becoming an entrepreneur think about
it like this if you go to college so you
want to be a doctor or a lawyer but
something they say that just to say you
want to be a CPA something that you need
a good college degree for you're gonna
have four years of school anywhere from
let's say twenty five to fifty thousand
dollars a year so your education is
gonna cost you a hundred thousand to two
hundred thousand dollars over a
four-year period you can join a trade
school either become a plumber become an
electrician a carpenter there's a lot of
different trade schools out there a
Mason it doesn't have to be just
plumbers and electricians
there's roofers there's ATSC tags you
bet there's a lot of different things
but the thing is is if you join a union
or a trade school and you get an
education over the four years which the
plumbers Union here in Dallas it's a
five year training program but over that
five years you start out at $17 an hour
and you end up right now I said about
thirty four thirty five dollars an hour
but five years from now when these young
men and women turn out it's gonna be
about $40 an hour so imagine if you've
got five years invested in your training
whether it's college or a trade school
four years of college plus one year out
looking for a job in getting a job
you're still entry-level position with
not much history much experience so
you're gonna be at an entry-level pay if
you go through the Union training
program as and I say Union training
program just because I used to teach in
the Union and I'm familiar with it
but if you join the Union at the same
time that you would have started college
now four or five years later you're
making 30 almost 40 dollars an hour
you've been making $17 an hour with four
raises a year since then so it's not
like you just go from 17 to 34 you go
from 17 to 19
twenty-one and it just keeps going up
but you've been making this kind of
money for four years so now instead of
having a student debt you've actually
had income so what if you just took that
money that you made and invested right
you stay living at home you go to school
and I used to know a welder he lived at
home with his parents he was driving a
brand new Chevy dually truck everywhere
he went and still putting money up
because he lived with his parents the
whole time to his apprentice training
program so he had put up you know
hundred two hundred thousand dollars
where would you rather be Oh somebody
100 or 200 or pocket 100 or 200 the big
Delta there big Delta and especially I
think a lot one of the biggest things I
would like my audience to know is that
the real way to become wealthy like
everyone's always talking about is
actually savings and investments I mean
everybody knows eventually you want to
get away from your working hours being
the way to make money individually your
investments that's definitely how the
ultra-wealthy
are making their money so you're right
getting that head start can make a huge
difference I have a friend who went into
HVAC after kind of like jumping around
jobs forever and he loves it I mean he
like when he first got in he's like I
don't really know if this is right for
me but four years down the line getting
that expertise getting that experience
now he likes going to work he loves what
he does and the other thing too is it
makes you a really hands-on guy I mean a
lot of people like myself I left college
you know I I when I graduated college I
can't fix the sink I can't I'm a
homeowner now and it's like some of the
stuff I'm having to like relearn I'm
like oh man I'm an engineer but
sometimes they you know like they're
gonna pipes and one of the cool things
about trades is that the people you
always see in the trades I know a few
people who trade they're extremely handy
like you give them any problem they'll
find a way to fix it and I think
something some people should think about
is when they think of hands-on stuff
you're usually talking about the trades
that's the job that's that's out there
doing it the engineers laying plans
they're in CAD they're in all these
things but
not actually on the ground in the field
and it's a neat way you put it is there
in CAD too my son started out he joined
the apprentice training program came up
to it he became a pipe fitter so pipe
fitter welder you know they go hand in
hand but what he did he is now working
in the estimating department he's on a
computer all day and he loves it he's
making six figures a year he's still got
his benefits he goes in at 6 o'clock
he's working on a computer they don't
care what time he's there he goes in at
6 he's off by 2:30 3 o'clock enjoys his
day but he's very mechanically inclined
because of the things that he learned
and how to use tools it's crazy
my wife there's so many times she's like
wanting to put my car in the shop for
this it's like well I'll do that
she just looks I mean she's like you can
do that it's like yeah man it's just
what kind of tools do you have and what
do you need to fix it that's what it
takes yeah so walk me through I mean you
said you you taught Union which I think
is really interesting so walk people
through let's say somebody sees this and
says hey man this sounds a lot better
than I thought
I want to learn more walk me through one
learning more which they can actually go
to your YouTube channel Rodger Wakefield
check that out but tell me a little bit
how they can learn more and also about
ok they decide they want to take that
next step what does that look like what
is that I've got some great videos about
that but one of the first things is the
questions that I asked a while ago you
need to be able to answer those do you
want to do residential or commercial do
you want to do new construction or
service do you want to be union or
non-union and let's go back even before
that one what trade do you want to do
I'm a plumber and I talk about plumbing
but everything that I'm talking about
right now could be for electrical for
HVAC for concrete for windows I mean
there's a million different things that
involve the trades but you need to
decide what would interest you because
what you don't want to do if you don't
like plumbing if you think oh my gosh if
I ever had to walk up to a stopped-up
toilet and that would never work
plumbing may not be for you but then
again if you're one of those guys I
don't
ever want to get shocked that would just
scare the heck out of me don't become an
electrician so figure out what you want
to do first then from there start
looking for a job or start looking for a
school if it's the Union you can go to
the United Association for plumbers
ibw for electro or for electricians
there's so many different unions and to
be honest one of the best ones to join
the elevator Union the guys that build
elevators have got the amazing benefits
in the world are you serious man I
thought I talked to an elevator guy one
day I was on a union job and I say Union
I was a union plumber at the time and
went over and talked to him and found
out that they were you know like man
that's really neat so tell me about it
they're set up where once you work over
I think it's fifteen hundred hours a
year
you're everything else starts adding so
you could literally retire in like 15
years with 30 years experience because
they get so many extra credits for
anything over a certain number of hours
and I'm like man I should join the
elevator Union but don't get me wrong
it's probably it's gonna be harder to
get in cuz there's there's not as much
residential work what you know and
there's not as much elevator work I
would think in a building is there as
plumbing but and at the end of the day
if you're just wanting a job that pays
good and has great benefits that would
be phenomenal you said that a lot of
your people Steven want to be
entrepreneurs think about it if you're a
plumber and even the plumbing license is
not really required in every state now
I'm in Texas there is a license here and
we're fighting for it but even as a
plumber I can go to school or let's just
say it this way I can go to school for
five years through a Department of Labor
training program I can get my journeyman
license after the first four years and
then after the fifth year I can get my
master license then really all I need is
of course the responsible master plumber
to own my own company
I recommend people get a little bit more
experienced than that if you want to do
residential service work residential
service and learn it and learn it well
learn business that's the biggest thing
that I had to learn whenever I finally
started my own company after 35 years of
working for other people I don't know
anything about running a business I'm a
great plumber I can walk into a house
and solve a problem and fix it but I
know nothing about business making the
phone ring paying taxes all the other
things that are involved right marketing
you know how hiring managerial right
yeah yeah that's really interesting but
at the same time you've got a lot of it
already solved which is you have that
hard skill a lot of people they want to
do they want to do the business side
first but they have what are they
selling they don't have anything to sell
they don't have any like actual hard
skill that puts them ahead of anybody
else they want a dropship on the
internet and they want so they want the
business side but they don't have the
hard skill that actually makes the
business side make sense and so that's
that's why I'm encouraging people to go
get a hard skill where you have some
kind of either credentialing or you have
if you want to do you know whatever it
be have some kind of hard skill that
sets you apart from other people so that
no matter what happens with your dreams
of owning your own business or anything
like anything else you can eventually
have a job wherever you go I mean that's
the thing about these trades is that
even if the business didn't work out
obviously you're doing very well now
even if the business didn't work out you
could always just go back and go do what
you've been doing Stephen what you just
said is I've actually got out of
plumbing before I moved to Austin and
was doing sprinkler work fire protection
systems I loved Austin so much and it
was the late 80s what a lot of
construction weren't going on I got into
the bar business I was a bartender and a
bouncer and whenever I moved back to
town I managed a restaurant for a little
while
actually became a cosmetologist and a
massage therapist Wow
I mean I used to have hair down to my
waist believe it or not but I could
always do that but I always I got back
into plumbing because I've always loved
it so what you just said I mean I could
shut my company down tomorrow move to
California and find a job plumbing and
you know since I'm part of the Union I
could even try to transfer through the
Union if I wanted to
the opportunities are phenomenal
and I have people from other countries
you know Africa New Zealand everywhere
reaching out saying like I want to come
to the United States and be a plumber
can I work for you and it blows their
mind when I said look I'm just a little
small company but I've grown to what I
have by learning the things that I
needed to learn and the big thing that
you said is I was a good plumber but I
didn't understand marketing that's what
brought me to social media marketing
world to start studying social media I
got tired of getting ripped off by
marketing companies oh yeah that's
that's a whole thing
I mean there is there's something to the
idea that if you want something done you
just gotta figure out how to do it
yourself
so ya know I mean social media is
definitely a trip but you seem like you
really get the hang of it your sets
really nice you how long have you been
at this just curious
put it this way I'll leave Saturday
morning to go to social media marketing
world two years ago I walked in for the
first time and knew nothing in the world
about social media ah so you've been at
you're a fast learner huh I've become a
student of it I love this I think what
the neatest thing about it is I have
people reach out to me and say hey I
want to be a plumber I saw your video
you've got me excited about it my
parents want me to go to college I'm
telling them no this is what I want to
do and man that just God that makes you
feel amazing that is that is really
amazing I want to actually go back to
something you said that I thought was
really interesting which is that the
part about people are really worried
about automation and he's robots taking
your job it's actually funny people
no this the first jobs that actually go
when you put when when AI and all that
stuff gets gets better is actually not
plumber jobs or anything requiring
getting out in the field it's always the
desk job that go first which is the
whole irony minor like you used to have
you know accountants well now you have
TurboTax we're just some robot does I
mean obviously there's still room for
accountants at the at the higher level
but what's what jobs are getting
squeezed out first it's the it's the
white-collar jobs and I think people are
missing that because I mean I've been
reading that you know blue-collar jobs
are experiencing people are expecting a
shortage because not enough people are
going into the trades so there's this
huge opportunity and it's not that we're
expecting it we're in the middle of it
I'm filing with the state of Texas right
now it's taking so long to get people
licensed that I mean we're short
plumbers you can contact any plumber in
the state that owns a company and ask
them what's your biggest problem and
it's the fact that handyman are out
doing our work they're not licensed
they're not doing it right but there's
not enough plumbers micro talks about it
mr. wonderful talks about it you know
we've got five trillion dollars I think
I'm student debt and we've got a million
unfilled trade jobs that I mean people
can walk right out of high school and
start doing it seems like this huge gap
that and that's actually why I started
I'm trying to start this this series is
it seems like there's a gap in people
who are leaving high school they don't
know what they want to do they know they
don't want to go to college but they
don't know what's next
it seems like there's an educational gap
in the opportunities that they have
because they think to themselves the
only thing I'm qualified for is to go
work at t.j.maxx
Oh a lot of burglaries here in Texas or
you know whatever have you some minimal
education job which might be fine to get
you whatever it's you a paycheck that's
always good but taking that next step I
don't think people realize how good of
an opportunity trades are I mean you can
get right in right out of high school
just like you said
you set yourself up for a real career
you have a job that can take you
anywhere I mean what am I missing here
that you're missing the best part it's
easy to get into yeah and I mean think
about it like I said while ago right now
if you get into plumbing here in the
Union apprentice training program in
Dallas right out of high school it
starts out in almost $17 an hour that's
a $34,000 your job right out of high
school and it's gonna be seventy-five
eighty thousand dollars by the time you
get out there's insurance that's paid
for by the employer there's a pension
plan so you've got a retirement plan I
don't get I think the biggest problem
that we've had is the public schools and
my wife as it used to be a teacher
we have forced college on students for
so long tell them look if you don't go
to college you're not gonna mount to
anything and I love that because I know
so many plumbers and electricians that
are a millionaire say okay y'all gonna
y'all go to college so y'all can afford
to pay my bills it is what it is I the
idea that like you trade schools they'll
they'll get you some you know they'll
get you maybe out of the poorhouse maybe
some people think you are poor if you
work trace there's this huge people
don't know that you can become a
millionaire doing these things it but
but you don't even have to become a
millionaire I mean when my wife married
me it blew her mind
I had a jeep I had a truck I had a
motorcycle I've got a nice house and
I've lived in this house for 20 years so
it's not like I just bought it after my
open my own company as a as a plumber
and we're gonna shoot a video this
afternoon you know the 10 tips you need
to know to make over $100,000 a year I
started making over a hundred thousand
dollars a year as a plumber I think it
was 1999 or 2000 I don't know that I've
made under a hundred thousand a year
since then and I've had some years that
actually got close to two hundred
thousand so and this is a plumber that
I'm not talking Roger the business owner
yeah
I'm talking Roger the plumber out
working a lot of hours and busting his
butt to make things happen and it works
and the funny thing is and everybody
thinks we'll you know the Union plumbers
and the construction and all that is
great and if I would have learned and
known what I know now is a residential
service plumber I'm in a plumber a while
back and was talking to him he makes 225
to 250 thousand a year he's a plumber
and a truck every day that's what he
does
Wow Wow got a bad gig it's it's all in
you you one of the old-school plumbers
and this is what's so great for the
young people coming up into it that
really are like look I want to learn
this as an old-school plumber and it was
hard for me to get over once I started
my own company I was that old-school
plumber I just wanted to run and fix the
problem get paid and leave run to the
next job now I've learned well if I walk
into your house and you've got a problem
here I want to figure out what caused
that problem do you need a water
filtration system because the chlorine
is eating up the the rubbers or the
gaskets or whatever the case may be
do you need an anti scale device because
you have extremely hard water and it's
messing up your tub and shower valve
well what you don't realize it's also
missing up your dishwasher your ice
maker your washing machine things that
you can't see so if I learn to come in
and say Steven look you've got a nice
toilet here but but this toilets 15
years old I can rebuild it here's the
cost to do it I can replace it for you
know a social toilet here's the cost to
do that or you can go this really nice
high in ultra efficient toilet what
would you choose
and that's what it is you give people
options and that first option maybe $400
the second option maybe eight the last
one maybe twelve
most people are gonna be like you know
what just give me the one in the middle
let's change it out so I'm saving some
water and do this and this and this
but it's giving people options letting
them know what is best for them and what
you would recommend and then just let
them choose so it's a bit I mean I mean
what you're talking about is somewhat of
sales it is about like being the being
the expert in the room teaching them and
that's that's something you learned as
you grew into the job of like okay let
me let me know if not just fix the
temporary problem let me actually go and
improve their life beyond that and the
extra bonus there is that you get to
upsell people on more products and you
make more life here's the way it was put
to me and this is where it really
clicked and I thought wow because I've
always been that guy like I'm not gonna
do sales I am not that kind of plumber I
don't want to be that kind of plumber
that's just wrong
and I was telling the guy this he said
okay so let me ask you this it's am i
right let me tell you a story he said
this doctor is on tour at the hospital
and he's checking the rooms and he walks
by and he sees a name that he knows and
he walks in he says mr. Johnson are you
ok he says well not really he says he
says your arm I mean everything's fine
he was in the doctor's office the day
before and they had to put a cast on it
he says oh god no my mom's fine he said
when I got home I had a massive heart
attack I almost died they had to bring
me to the hospital and now I'm in here
doctor says yeah I knew that yesterday
he said well why didn't you say anything
about his domain your blood pressure was
out of the out of the out of the roof it
was crazy he said well why didn't you
tell me so maybe you're just like a
charm fixed so think about it like that
I mean if you've got a problem
why not tell somebody say hey look by
the way your blood pressure's crazy you
may be fixing to have a heart attack or
stroke them let's run a test let's do
this let's check this out you may need
to do this why not why not be the same
way with plumbing
and that change I mean yeah that totally
makes sense why that would change the
game because you really are the expert
in the room you know what's going on and
regardless of whether you want to do
sales I mean I think what you're saying
is it's a matter of just being the
experts to inform somebody what's going
on in their house they may have never
known so what we lose the difference
between I want to change the subject a
little bit I walk because you said you
need to answer residential or commercial
let's start there what's the difference
in the experience of a plumber well
remember and I that question for people
wanting to start out the residential
you're gonna build houses what's neat
about it you'll you'll normally learn
all the phases you'll get in you'll work
on the underground you'll come back a
few days later you'll do a top out come
back a few days later you'll set
fixtures and those are really the three
phases now on commercial jobs are
normally so big you're probably just
gonna you're gonna run water you're
gonna do cast-iron or you're gonna do
things like that they don't have all the
plumbers on the job at the same time
meaning when we broke ground on Parkland
Hospital we didn't have 200 plumbers
therefore the underground there were
five or ten plumbers and in quality
control and superintendents and things
like that as the job gets bigger and
you're working in more areas then you
bring in more plumbers so normally
plumbers have their specialty you know
hey look man I can run the heck out of
cast iron I run water lines I run gas
lines I pop fit i weld whatever it is
you bring them in as you need them then
you either cut them listen them to
another job whatever it is residential
service is a little bit different even
residential building you know the the
jobs go so fast you really probably
don't specialize on anything you can do
it all now service is a little bit
different service or let's go back to
residential commercial one thing that's
helped people about commercial is if
you're one of these people you love
going to the same place every day over
and over and over again because some of
these big commercial jobs may last two
or three years
so you know me whenever I was at it I
did the I was a superintendent over the
remodel for a terminal and a terminal at
DFW I was out there for five years
and you get used to going I mean you get
up you leave the house at 4:00 you're on
the toll road you hit the airport at
5:00 you get into your office you do
your stuff you go to meet the guys at
6:00 it you it's the same thing every
day
now I come in I've turned on my computer
I get on social media I go through and
check the book where do I have guys
going today start looking at what all we
may need where are they gonna be here
what's the schedule look like how can I
rearrange things to make it better but
as a residential plumber come
constructionwise you're normally gonna
be on the job a couple of days at a time
then you're gonna be on another one
service wise whether your commercial or
residential you're gonna like a
residential service plumber may see
three or four jobs a day a commercial
service plumber may see one or two
because normally the problems are bigger
more entailed and it may take a little
bit longer to fix that's a great I think
that's perfect I mean because what the
first thing I thought was when you said
you have to be able to answer these
questions before you get started I
thought well unless you know what
actually goes into it how do you know
who you know which one you want to be so
that gives a good lesson for people just
what you said if you like going to the
same place every day you're someone who
loves that routine I know I'm not that
person I like doing a different thing
every day but absolutely other people
and I know I I can rattle off ten names
right now that they want to do the same
thing the same way every single day and
what you're saying is well the two
different job styles are very different
and they fit different people so I think
that's good to your point about the
versatility of this job and the thing is
when I started remember when I started I
was doing commercial work it was
construction and I was non-union now I'm
residential service Union so just cuz
you start out somewhere it doesn't mean
that's where you're gonna end up but now
that I know as much as I do I tell
people look think about what you like to
do
it may help you stay in this trade
longer and and let this become a career
that you really love people that like to
be somewhere different every day like
you and I man you put them on a
commercial job that's gonna last three
years and after they're gonna six months
are like man I'm done I want out of here
you bet so let's talk about things
you've learned owning your own business
I think that's an interesting wrinkle in
the whole thing I I think so you said
you've been doing it what 30 35 years
before you start your own company about
35 years so the biggest shift had to
have been going from being on that scale
of I'm doing the job that I've been
assigned to do and then all of a sudden
you've got the keys you're in the
driver's seat and it's what do I need to
get done I mean that's that's a huge
shift in your whole mindset what are
some lessons you've learned from that
and it's not necessarily what needs to
get done is what has to get done
you know you sign up with these
customers and they call you and say hey
we want you to come and they expect you
to come take care of them and the thing
is and it's funny because I had this
conversation yesterday most people when
they start out everything is about
transactions they have to make money so
every relationship they have is
transactional it's all hey I need to
make money I'm gonna do this I'm gonna
do this I started a little bit different
I knew I wanted everything to start out
as a relationship so I literally I
started getting out to real estate
companies going in and meeting and
talking to real estate agents going in
and explaining to real estate agents
what we do and why we do it and how we
do it I don't want to be like every
other plumbing company out there I
wanted to be different so we all run
into the same problem how do I make the
phone ring and that's where I would hire
marketing companies and Steven we've
actually hired marketing companies that
made our phone stopped ringing
they changed the webpage they do this
they do this and it was so bad we
pick up our cell phones to call the
number just to see if the phone would
ring and it's like okay what did we do
here and I call them OPM marketing other
people's money marketing and that's what
those companies are all about and I
finally got tired of it because it would
literally be like hey look we need the
fund or ring more they'll be like well
how much more money you got it was like
well what's that got to do with anything
well we want all the money you've got to
spend on marketing to make it ring and
to me that really shouldn't be what it's
about I wanted to build the
relationships with people
that's what carried me over to social
media walk me through sort of a day in
the life at this point because obviously
you're much like me I mean I understand
that your days probably aren't all alike
but uh
walk me through now that you're the
great Roger Wakefield you've been doing
it for 40 pitchers what are you doing
these days
I mean you're not in the field anymore
or are you oh I still AM I like I said
my company's in Dallas Texas where I
Chilean Richardson I lead plumbers we
are short plumbers I cannot find good
plumbers and that's why I'm still out in
the field the opportunities that I have
coming in through social media far could
outweigh what I'm doing and plumbing but
I am tied down to the plumbing company
and I mean I'm looking for great people
but my normal day is I'll get up I'll
come in I'm normally in the office
between 6:00 or 7:00 I'm normally doing
social media from vent hole up to about
8 o'clock I grab the book look at it see
what we got on the book we do a huddle
or a meeting with our guys every morning
and then I jump in the truck I went out
a couple of weeks ago and estimated a
job where we we're tunneling up under a
house and three different areas one to
make repairs to to grab the pipe stub it
out front and reroute it around this
morning I had to go out lay that out
meet the Digg crew get them started I
left there and when
to another job where we have been
tunneling and I need to talk to the
homeowner and let her know there's still
problems there and we went in and fix
every all the big leaks that we found
but now we know that there's more and
these are very expensive projects so I
want to make sure that I'm there to talk
to him I got yesterday I was on a roof
on stopping a sewer we had to climb up
on a roof and run a server machine down
it actually grabbed my one of my video
guys before we went out and said man
come on we're gonna climb up on a roof
and stop the service we're gonna shoot a
video and that's exactly what we did I
think for some people you know I I just
I just hear it a lot from some of my
friends not so much of my comment
section but I know so many people who
they said I'm a guy who likes to work
with my hands I hear that all the time a
lot of guys that way you bet and yet
they don't go for the trades and exactly
what you just said I mean that's so
interesting
go jump up on a roof go solve the
problem next day you're tunneling
underground I mean I just don't think
that's what a lot of people think they
think you're gonna go jump in the new
york city sewers and be down there and
that's that's all they think of a collar
yeah and the funny you mention that
because now that I'm on social media
I've got to cut me out of New York
contacting me there's a thing called
fatbergs and what fatbergs are and you
really need to look it up because it is
a gosh a power wad of baby wipes paper
condoms anything people flush down the
toilets that build up in the sewer they
had one in London I think they said it
was as I mean this thing weighed like a
hundred tons it was as long as seven
buses I mean this thing was huge and it
started clogging up their sewers well I
had a company from New York call me and
say hey we wanted to do a documentary on
that would you be interested in being
the plumber that goes down and looks at
it and talks to I'm like and I have no
problem with that let's go but but it's
like stuff like that interests me it's I
love plumbing and for me to get to be in
an area
to see things that other plumbers may
never see down in the the New York
sewers to look at you know wow the sewer
line is you know 12 feet tall we're used
to running four-inch pipe there's a big
difference it's huge oh yeah so then
that the interesting thing is my normal
life as a plumber changes daily and you
know you put it really good it I was
under a house a couple of days ago I was
on a roof yesterday now you may be going
down and tackling the 7 foot 7 bus long
that's crazy
they're called fatbergs FA TB ERG is an
iceberg but a Fatburger is that your
Moby Dick I mean is that you're like
you're the cat man that's that would be
it
we all take a picture of me next to this
place dude they don't want to take a
picture they want to get a documentary
on you yeah it's crazy but I mean it did
it it almost shut down the London sewer
systems they've had problems with it
here I think in Michigan in New York
some different places and I mean this
isn't just a company this is a company
like hey we produce shows for HGTV for
Netflix for DIY for this and that and
they're like you know would you be
interested in doing this I'm like oh
yeah that's great we're going to see you
on the we're gonna get you off YouTube
but you're gonna be on cable man well
and I'm not gonna get off YouTube cuz
here's my thing I love being on YouTube
because of the engagement effect it I
mean think about it you send a message
to me the other day and said hey can we
talk I love that because I have people
send me messages saying hey look I want
to get in the trades but I've got
questions okay what questions have you
got and they're like wow you called it's
like well you you sent me your number
you know you wanted to talk so I love it
I love the fact that I'm in a position
now where I can help people change their
lives
perfectly said on that note I think
we're gonna start wrapping up here I
mean I think this
you've answered a lot of my questions
and the biggest thing is I want to keep
these episodes short enough to be
engaging but also so people know you
know is this right for me
I think you've spoken wonderfully to the
huge opportunities obviously this isn't
a field that's saturated you were saying
yourself it's almost impossible to find
people you're always looking for more
people and as our plumbing companies
around the United States so give me kind
of your wrap-up pitch for why people
let's say they're out of high school
they don't know what they're doing in
their life why should they get into
plumbing and the trades it's something
that you can literally decide what you
want to do I got in everybody gets in as
an apprentice and people tell me all the
time I don't know anything about it
nobody does when they get in whether
it's plumbing whether it's electrical
HVAC it really doesn't matter we don't
know what we don't know we get in we
learn it and then we can do what we want
to as a plumber just a plumber you can
be a plumber a foreman a superintendent
a general superintendent there's
possibilities of moving up running crews
leading Cruz in a residential service
company you can be an Operations Manager
or service manager so there's room for
growth then if you're willing to educate
yourself a little bit more you can learn
AutoCAD you can learn estimating you can
even learn to be a project manager
just because you say look I don't want
to do this forever
okay there's opportunities to come in
from out of the field set behind a desk
in front of a computer and do a job but
this might also be your best opportunity
to ever work for yourself if you one day
want to own your own company and think
about it in less than five years I'm
running a company that's doing a million
dollars a year in revenue that's not a
bad income for a owner also when I'm out
in the field I work for myself I have
the opportunity to build the company the
way I want to build it to have the
culture that we want to have so that we
can always do the right thing to take
care of our customers
that's a cool thing to say that's very
cool to say thank you so much Roger for
coming on the show you're welcome I
thoroughly enjoyed it same here
guys thanks for watching consider the
trades consider plumbing give it a shot
it's a lot you have a lot better of a
chance than with e-commerce I'll tell
you that right now give up the Guru's
pick up a wrench
go to work Thank You Roger thank you I
appreciate it saving
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
for the car
[Music]